each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so this morning we're very pleased
to have mahir Belari from University of
California San Diego visiting us he'll
be speaking on cryptography from theory
to practice mahir Belari is a well-known
cryptographer who along with raga way to
find the random Oracle model he's also a
co-inventor of the H Mac algorithm which
is widely used in in industry he's a
recipient of packard fellowship and an
NSF Career Award so we're indeed very
pleased to have me here visiting us here
today thank you oh good morning and
thanks for the kind introduction when
add the given the opportunity to speak
he had several choices for what to do
and I thought maybe people are expected
to give some kind of big vision talk but
I'm not much into these nebulous visions
so this is more of a pedagogical and
rather than try to select one specific
result to talk about I thought I'd
consider a broader topic and which is to
look at cryptography through the lens
that is motivated most of my work which
is bringing theory to practice and I
apologize in advance to the experts in
case a lot of what they see is is
something they know or and also for the
fact that to make things simple I'm
mostly selected relatively old work for
examples but I'm happy to discuss new
work in person so with that I have
cryptography from theory to practice and
with great thanks to Tom wrist in part
for his PowerPoint magic that makes this
possible so let me begin by asking if
you used any cryptography recently and
I'll venture that whether you know it or
not you you're likely to have done so
something that was once largely a
military interest is now in widespread
use you can figure this out any time
your URL changes from HTTP to have an S
at the end indicating use of the TLS or
SSL protocols
or some of their siblings which are
widely used for for internet secure
communication it's also for example if
you make an Internet purchased where you
pay with a credit card you'll be using
cryptography in these ways but even more
prosaically every time you use an ATM
machine you use cryptography while
preparing the talk I was channel surfing
and interesting to find that it even
shows up in James Bond movies where one
of the bad guys in this one talks about
using SSL it's hard to get more popular
than that so what is the subject about
the core problem is communication over
an insecure medium and there are a
couple of different goals one of them is
data privacy which means we want to
prevent the adversary who is in control
of the network from seeing the content
of the communication and the other one
is integrity or authenticity which means
that we want to ensure that the data
received originates from where it claims
to and wasn't modified in transit and
these goals apply to pretty much all
kinds of settings you could think of for
example Bob could be a doctor requesting
a medical record from Alice the database
the privacy ensures that the this the
sensitive contents and medical
information are not revealed and the
authenticity ensures that the record
really originates with the database are
not someone else if you are transmitted
a credit card number over the Internet
then the privacy relates to the fact
that the number itself isn't made known
in the authenticity to the fact that the
credit card number originates with the
rightful owner to achieve these goals
cryptographers construct algorithms
which process the data so what's
actually transmitted is a is a cipher
text and these opera these albums all
operate under the influence of keys
there's a several settings for this if
the key being held by the two parties is
the same we call it the symmetric
setting and we also have an asymmetric
setting in which
the encryption key and decryption key
are actually different and moreover the
encryption key can be known to not just
the adversary but any potential sender
which makes it more flexible but also
more expensive so some of the rules of
the game here are that algorithms should
be considered objects that are known
their public standardized and present in
software so any security comes out of
the secrecy of keys we can distinguish
here between computer security where the
goal is to protect the system on which
the cryptography is being executed and
in particular protect the keys from
exposure due to system and software
holes and cryptography which kind of
assumes that you have a secure system
underneath you and is worried about how
you use these keys and will the
algorithms for it to get secure
communication on the network and it's
the latter that I will be concentrating
on not because the former is not
important but just because this is a
good abstraction boundary to draw on and
the fields of different kinds of tools
and this happens to be my my expertise
so the questions were interested then is
how we design these algorithms to
achieve whatever security goes we all
have and we tend to call these
algorithms schemes or protocols what
makes cryptography hard to get right is
that it has to withstand attacks and
attacks it's hard to predict how
someone's going to try to attack your
scheme and failures do occur for example
the web wireless protocol had some poor
cryptography which resulted in pretty
well-known failures failures are costly
for two reasons one is the publicity
negative publicity and the other is
changes to software which are expensive
so a lot of the goal of cryptography is
to try to prevent failures a classical
way to do that is to begin by analyzing
a scheme and then attempt to break it
and if you succeed in breaking it while
you iterate and until you can come to a
point where you have a scheme of which
you feel reasonably confident the people
who attempt
break these schemes are called
cryptanalysts and their expertise is to
is to mimic attackers and try to figure
out what the weaknesses are and
eventually one hopes to come to a scheme
where these experts don't really have a
way to break it what one needs to
understand about this process is that
the confidence you're getting in
securities is somebody's view that they
themselves can't find an attack it's not
a indication that attacks are guaranteed
to be absent and one I can raise certain
concerns about this approach one of them
is that we achieve our confidence by by
trust in experts that's not necessarily
a bad thing but some of the its
difficulties are that it doesn't scale
well there's far fewer of these experts
then we have schemes being created so
for example the Microsoft you're not
lucky lucky to have news Ferguson lose
one of the experts in this area but
imagine if every single crypto
containing product had to be passed by
him before you deployed it it simply
become a bottleneck in in the process so
we'd like things that that scale better
and unfortunately many people think that
they can do crypt analysis quite well
and try to do it on their own and then
and then they get it wrong so the
alternate metal methodology on I was
like to consider begins with with the
people here at MIT and when you start
using it you probably begin the same way
as before you design some scheme you try
to break it and you iterate until you
get to a scheme that seems reasonable in
the sense that you probably can't find
an attack but you don't stop there what
the methodology that they've developed
can do is offer you some kind of proof
that not only can a certain person not
find an attack but there's some sort of
evidence that other people are not going
to find find it either and the advantage
of this is that you get some car sort of
verifiable certificate of security
which you can check and and can and
allow other people to check and thereby
gain confidence in the in the algorithm
so there's a few things there that I'd
like to explain more depth about this
methodology in particular white says and
what it means that nobody is likely to
not that they actually can and secondly
how you can possibly get proofs for for
security so we start with some desired
end go end goal which is to design a
scheme are called why and it might be
for some task that we want to do over
the internet like encryption of data or
authentication of data now historically
people may have approached the task of
designing this scheme by simply sitting
down there and starting to write some
algorithm but modern cryptography
doesn't do that what we have is a set of
tools or problems from which we start
and view those as as something we call
atomic primitives they might be
mathematical problem so there might be
certain constructs that have been
engineered by cryptographers as an
example the factoring problem is that I
give you a composite number and ask you
to find the practice well this is pretty
easy for a small number but once it gets
big it's hard to figure out how to do it
and this is a task that as far as a
legend goes has even daunted Gauss and
certainly no one's done any better so
far the difficulty with something like
this is that it's not a cryptographic
solution it's a mathematical problems to
solve to factor a big number and we need
to see how we can actually use that to
to encrypt a large file so what
cryptographers do is transform these
atomic low level primitives into high
level ones and when we talk about proofs
are in particular about security we're
largely we're concerned with the
security of this transformation process
historically or empirically it turns out
that atomic primitives tend to be much
more stable and secure than the schemes
we built for them they're relatively few
of
then although they're sometimes subject
to attack they are studied in depth by
experts and we can have reasonable
confidence in them but the number of
schemes that people are designing on
them is huge in Microsoft they're
probably hundreds of pieces of
cryptography at this end of the spectrum
but they all use this transformation
process starting from a small set of
primitives it seems that we tend to put
bugs in when we do this transform and
what the proof process does for us is
say that this transformation process
works in the sense given here of a
reduction which says that if you give me
any way to attack this scheme by some
adversary alcohol is some why then I
have a way to turn it into an adversary
that attacks this scheme read backwards
it means that if you have confidence in
the atomic perimeter it automatically
translates to confidence in the
higher-level primitive and the
advantages of this are that not that you
have done away with crypt analysis but
that you've confined it to a smaller set
of things so that the cryptanalytic
talents in the community are not kind of
spread out and wasted over too much
stuff but can be used on the things that
actually matter and the rest of the
confidence can come mathematically I'd
like to point out that that sometimes
people who look at proofs of you does as
anti crypt analysis that's really not my
perspective what I rather believe is
that crypt analysis asana is an
important and valued trait in the
community and what proofs do is leverage
it better rather than allow it to be
kind of dispersed across too many things
one of the centerpieces of what this
methodology is about is that when we use
the term of breaking something it has a
precise definition underlying by precise
model and a consequence of that is that
we know what assumptions were making and
against what class of attacks were
secure so you get a much better
understanding of what kind of security
you're getting from this process
provable security isn't the panacea
Niels
give you many examples of Pro Bowl
security schemes is broken some of the
reasons things can go wrong that
although you did provide a formal model
you didn't capture some some threats
that were later seeing to be relevant a
neat little example of this is when the
encryption which was shown to meet
certain security notions and theory but
they didn't cover the attacks that that
could actually be mounted in the system
and hence was broken another example is
attacks that go outside the model by by
looking at things like the the time
taken by your program to execute or the
variation in its power consumption and
things like that and if your models
didn't take this into account well then
little fall to these threats you have to
implement it correctly doesn't help to
have a proof if you don't you do assume
your atomic primitives are good if they
aren't and that happens sometimes the
most spectacular case recently was when
collisions were found for hash functions
then of course all bets are off if you
get a proof you better get it right
otherwise it's also worthless one of the
things we I often feel about the way we
do proofs is that I can't verify some of
the proofs in the literature as dubious
how valuable they are in this case but
even given all these caveats I I do feel
that provable security is valuable on
the whole it can give you increased
confidence and scheme security and it's
something that people can learn to use
and be educated about in a way that's
more difficult for an art like crypt
analysis which is somehow requires just
a kind of cleverness which which you
don't necessarily need if you just have
to check proves approval security is
good and that it makes clear the models
and assumptions and use and can be
communicated as a rough analogy in case
you don't know about this area much
proof of security is very much like an
NP completeness proof it's not telling
you if you remember the story from Gary
& Johnson's book
your boss asks you to solve some problem
and you come back the next day and you
say you don't know how to do it and he's
not very impressed but then you say i
don't but nor do all these famous people
because it's NP complete and equivalent
to all these other things it's somehow
the same principle you're saying that
your your scheme is secure because if
not then a lot of problems that a lot of
clever people like gauss have studied
would become easy and and we don't
believe that okay so that was kind of a
background my story begins here I was a
graduate student at MIT where we learned
all about the theory and and the
beautiful frameworks for proofs and all
kinds of notions and generally were
given the impression that that we could
solve all the world's problems and after
that I got a job at IBM in a group which
was working on a on a high-speed network
and they felt like they wanted a
cryptographer and what I found was that
things were extremely different the kind
of cryptography and words we were seeing
in practice with things like block
ciphers des things like CBC encryption
or Mac lots and lots of standards for
for doing cryptography protocols for
session key exchange and when one look
to see what the theory had to say about
this well the answer was basically
nothing none of these things were
covered or in theory a course at MIT
didn't even mention des they don't and
they didn't seem to have any knowledge
or or interest in these kinds of topics
that didn't mean that they were idle
there was an entire framework of
cryptography and theory based on
assumptions like one-way functions
achieving goals like zero knowledge
talking about proven secure public key
encryption and signatures and when one
looked to what that was happening with
that in practice well basically nothing
no one was using that or seemed to be
influenced by anything like that at all
and this was the gap that kind of
motivated our work and my work with Phil
raaga way was about bridging this gap
and what we did was provide schemes that
for which
we could give proofs but which reflected
practical constraints and problems in in
a way that made them usable and if one
wants them all very simple let's say
oversimplified view of where what the
source of the gap was you could say it's
effectively performance so theoretical
slims were slow and practitioners linear
things are a lot faster but this gap
wasn't something that you could change
by writing faster code or something like
that it was the gap was enormous it was
factors of millions and billions and
more than that and what we found is that
the gap didn't arise from from say
levels of detail but from major cultural
what I would like to call cultural
differences in the way these two
communities looked at things and it's
I'd like to examine those differences
and what we have been trying to do to
change them to bridge this gap is kind
of the focus of my talk so one of the
main and first differences we found was
in what people viewed as appropriate
atomic primitive so remember the atomic
perimeters are the things you start with
as given before you start building
schemes in practice we saw a set of
parameters that were built by what
people call the confusion diffusion
paradigm which means that they were
engineered by by crypt analysts who
studied them and try to make them secure
and include things like block ciphers
and hash functions what theory was using
is things arising from mathematics like
one-way functions factoring discrete log
RSA and things like that and if you ask
the theoretician their general view of
what practitioners use as primitives was
was quite negative they thought of them
as ugly objects which really shouldn't
be looked at and had no place in in the
theory the answer the practitioners was
that well if you think our stuff is so
bad why don't you try to break it and by
and large that turned out to be true in
the sense that these things were not
broken and their performance gap between
these things was incredible so we would
say
unreasonable to say that this group of
people should move to this viewpoint now
the reason I call this a cultural gap is
that the theory community hadn't looked
at what the practitioners did analyzed
it and decided that is bad it was at
some sort of level of taste that they
viewed these things as something that
just shouldn't be considered and it
reflects probably just the origins of
this community in complexity theory and
mathematics whereby engineered objects
which are built by hand based on
principles that are maybe sound but held
implicitly by experts was just somehow
not to their taste now another confusion
and might like to eradicate before I go
on is that from these call-outs you
might think these groups of people
actually talk to another each other but
they never did that whatever I've seen
here are things that they've said to me
when I ask them questions or or
communicate to each other so what Phil
and I did is to bring these types of
primitives into the fabric approval
security by supplying appropriate
definitions and models under which you
can use them and once you do that what
we found is that you can build
cryptography just as well on the back of
confusion diffusion has on number theory
and and this is a gap which in fact one
could spend an entire lecture on in many
ways once you start looking at it you
see that these primitives have greater
strength than the ones here they have
different varieties of strengths ones
which in some cases are harder to
capture by models but which seem to be
present and also they have strengths
simply due to the fact that Krypton is
just a much higher targets they expect
things in some sense to be much stronger
than in this domain and that's why
things are often viewed as broken here
which may not really reflect weaknesses
I'm happy to say that subsequent to our
work this has become relatively standard
so by now a lot of papers in the
literature use our assumptions and
methods to work
cough these kinds of primitives and bill
probably secure schemes on them a second
cultural difference we found is in
concrete versus asymptotic security the
way theoreticians model security is to
have a parameter called a security
parameter which goes to infinity and so
that any scheme is actually a collection
of schemes one for every value of this
parameter and the advantage of an
adversary which is its success
probability is a function of this
security parameter in practice however
many of the primitives have no parameter
going to infinity the AES block cipher
has 128 bit keys and input outputs and
that's all there is what theoreticians
dub security is to say that they are
schemes where polynomial time
adversaries can't break it in the sense
that as the security parameter goes to
infinity so does their success
probability now they have a specific
definition which says that the rate at
which this function goes to infinity is
something for example it's less than the
reciprocal of any polynomial and that's
called a negligible function the
difficulty with this approach is that if
you want security like practitioners do
who say well we want to know what
happens when you have an attacker that
has two to the 50 running time and we
want to make sure it doesn't have this
much success probability is in principle
this tells you nothing because all it
tells you is that as the security
parameter goes to infinity things get
reasonable and it's not clear what
polynomial time is in the context of 2
to the 50 now again one of the reasons i
call this gap cultural is that it's not
as though there's an enormous technical
difference between these two it's more
that the people who develop theory had
their origins in complexity theory and
viewed cryptography is an extension of
complexity classes like p and BP p and
NP and to them it was natural to
translate that framework into the
definitions here so that you got
polynomial time adversaries and security
parameters which function just as the
length of the input in complexity theory
and they just somehow didn't feel like
they could develop a theory
around things like this and our
contribution there was to produce is to
is to bridge this gap by producing
provable security statements in this
type of framework by appropriate models
and definitions and results now again
this is a perspective that this gap is
something one could spend a whole
lecture on but it is kind of interesting
in the way that it developed once the
culture of theory was fixed to this a
large fraction of them followed it you
know continuous leave after that without
trying to make a change but nonetheless
some fraction of the community has since
switched over into a viewpoint and into
concrete complexity in particular for
example work on pairing base
cryptography employs this now in this
some another way to look at this gap in
my perspective is to consider the
theoretical computer science has people
working in complexity theory and in
algorithms algorithms are people who
care about whether an algorithm runs in
time and cubed or order N squared log n
which are which are highly different to
them complexity theory is largely just
care about whether something is
polynomial time or not in some sense
cryptography never developed an
algorithms community it stayed a
community where people were interested
in polynomial time as opposed to finer
grained measures of efficiency it's also
you you can see cryptographers improving
efficiency and giving you know
algorithms which are computationally
more efficient but when they disregard
concrete security that actually turns
out to be effectively vacuous and this
done seemed to be understood to do
greater next time anyway a final gap
here was in goals Theory tended to focus
only on public key cryptography in
public key encryption and signatures and
then lots of fascinating higher level
goals like the ones listed here but
ninety percent or more of the
cryptography that actually goes on in
practice is in the symmetric setting and
there are also problems like
key distribution which I found has seems
to have more incorrect protocols out
there than any primitive I've seen in
cryptography and was not being addressed
in in theory at all and the
theoreticians viewed symmetric
cryptography is kind of a special case
of asymmetric isn't this just something
stronger in fact that view isn't even
correct in the sense that even
definitionally they're not the same but
the performance gap is huge due to the
fact that you can use confusion
diffusion primitives this gets you know
thousands to tens of times thousand
times faster in the most basic
asymmetric encryption so our focus was
on developing solutions and definitions
and models in this domain okay so the
rest of my talk is a bunch of examples
to illustrate these um these ideas more
concretely and talk about some specific
results and I guess I'll go through as
many of them as you have patience for
and then stop the first one is about
encryption so I want to first talk about
the basic underlying limiter which is
block ciphers so block cipher is just a
map which under the influence of a key
transforms an input of sun block length
be say 128 bits into an output of the
same length and if you have the key you
can not only go forwards but backwards
des for example has certain parameters
of key and block length the modern AES
has has different ones and how do these
things work well there are that's again
a topic for a book or something but here
for example is a high-level description
of the AES cipher and as you can see
it's a it just kind of operates through
rounds each of which mangoes the bits of
the input under the influence of the key
and here this one relies on numerous
subroutines that are not going to talk
about but maybe it's enough to get some
kind of flavor traditionally when people
have discussed security what they mean
by this is security against key recovery
all the security comes from the key and
what we want is if an adversary has
input output examples of the cipher it
should have a hard time figuring out the
key one of the things i will do is
update this view
and that's part of our push to develop
models for atomic primitives which are
useful to get to show security of the
end goes we'll have to update this one
now naively at least a block cipher
allows you to encrypt if I have a b-bit
message I can encrypt it by applying the
block cipher into this key and send it
to a bomb so so why aren't we done well
just for a simple pragmatic reason that
you can buy this method only encrypt a
128-bit plaintext and that's not what
you want you want to encrypt longer
messages so we do that by something
called modes of operation and this is
where we can see the sort of paradigm
that have been discussing emerge in this
process we view the block ciphers and
atomic perimeter and we are aiming to
construct by some transform some
primitive that's more directly useful
for applications and which we call a
symmetric encryption scheme so and that
too is a process that takes a key and
process our input to an output but the
difference from a block cipher is that
the message as arbitrary length and the
process could actually be randomized now
there are numerous choices for how we
might do this transform and build the
encryption scheme and here are the most
common ones the electronic code book
mode is the most obvious you just break
your message into blocks and apply the
block cipher on each block a little more
involved is cipher block chaining and
it's most interesting feature is that
every time you encrypt you pick a random
number and you and that random number
influences this process through chaining
has shown in the picture the cipher text
is longer than the plaintext by
including this random number and it
turns out although it's not shown here
that if you have the ciphertext and the
key you you can decrypt this thing so
then the questions we would have about
these things are are they secure is one
better than the other so forth now it
turns out that CBC encryption is in some
sense the world's most used encryption
scheme that's the one that's deployed or
some
tensions of variants of it I deployed
pretty much everywhere and that's how
things get encrypted so too so what Phil
and I were interested in was
understanding how secure this is since
its impact on real-world cryptography is
is really pretty immense so to answer
that question we here's where we kind of
step back to take a theoretical
perspective is we wanted to first know
exactly what one means by something
being secure the traditional idea was
the same as for the block cipher which
is that if you had some inputs and
outputs you couldn't figure out the key
now under this metric electronic code
book mode is actually secure because
having input and output examples and
trying to figure out the key is no
different for the encryption scheme than
from the block cipher so if you believe
you have a good block cipher this is a
good encryption scheme and yet
practitioners for a long time had
already understood that electronic code
book mode is bad and looking at why does
the solicitor is useful to illustrate
that security goals are things that you
need to kind of formulate with more care
so let's do that so across the lake in
in Seattle they have their voting for
example on a proposition which is what
quite a bit of money and let's say that
the vote was being encapsulated in the
following way so let's say you submitted
your ballot at some polling station and
let's say this polling station shared a
key with some tallying center and when
it got your wart it encrypted it and
sent it across and let's say that they
they encoded votes as one block strings
so ECB now simply comes down to
application of the block cipher so if
elaine's vote was yes this is what would
get transmitted and let's say Jerry had
some other vote done v2 we don't know
its value yet then this is what will get
transmitted what you now see though is
that even without knowing the key or
without computing it is very easy for
this person to figure out what this
person voted because this
process is deterministic and if V 2 was
equal to Y C 1 would equal C 2 and
otherwise it wouldn't because this this
there's a permutation so just by
examining whether or not these two
things are the same all security here is
lost Ln can completely figure out what
what Jerry's loaders so this is the kind
of thing that we consider a flaw in the
encryption scheme and would like to
avoid so that kind of throws this
encryption scheme out but we'd like to
to analyze other ones now in order to go
further with that though we'd like to
pin down more precisely what does what
the security go we just discussed is and
for that cryptographers create formal
models and I thought I'd try to
illustrate one of them so this is the
definition that Phil and I gave for
symmetric encryption and it just
imagines a game in which you have an
adversary and it's interaction of the
encryption scheme is via a certain
Oracle the adversary can produce not one
with two messages of its choice and ask
the Oracle to encrypt and the Oracle
will encrypt not both of them but one of
them the only thing is it won't tell the
adversary our priority which of the two
it's encrypting and the encryption is
done under a key the adversary doesn't
know at the end of this process they
obviously can make many such queries at
the end of that it's going to try to
figure out or which of the two was being
encrypted that's all it's trying to
figure out now this is a relatively
simple extension of the same definition
given by Galvis and Macaulay in the
asymmetric setting but there are some
differences in the symmetric setting in
particular the fact that you need these
Oracle's because the keys are our hidden
you we assign a measure of success to
the adversary it's not the probability
that B prime equals B because that can
always be a half by a simple guess but
some reflection of the extent to which
this probability exceeds one half
already here we are seeing a concrete
security approach because here in theory
nobody defined this function they were
just say that
the difference of this probability to
one half is negligible or something like
that and merely writing this down will
enable us to do more with that so this
advantage measure is going to depend on
a number of things like a strategy but
also by how on how many queries it makes
how much computing time it has and so
forth and so when we talk about security
I'll use this terminology
indistinguishability and the chosen
plaintext attack to reflect the type of
goal and loosely speaking say that
security just means that this number is
small for any adversary whose resource
usage is is practical doesn't exceed a
practical amounts of running time this
is not a formal definition because it
doesn't define what small impractical
are but that's kind of essential to a
concrete approach in reality security is
not a boolean attribute it depends on
the resources and attacker invests and
in theory you would say something like
well the attacker success probably is
negligible in that security but then
it's difficult to translate that to
practice yeah
one and one
sure so it could do that and if it sends
okay if it sends on 0m0 it's get back
the tack you're talking about will work
if the encryption is deterministic so
that's a great point and in particular
it proves that that's still in some
sense this is why this captures ECB
failing so one of the implications of
this is that any good encryption scheme
has to be randomized so when you send em
0m0 the first time and then in your
third step you said to again send m0 m1
the coins used in the two cases would be
different and so even if you twice
encrypt the m0 it won't look the same
okay so that kind of loosely says what
we mean by secure encryption we need a
similar definition for the block cipher
and it won't be security against key
recovery it's what's called being a
pseudo-random permutation and here I'll
skip the precise formulation but the
intuition is that the input-output
behavior of the block cipher is
resembles that of a random permutation
the important caveat is only to someone
who doesn't know the key but only sees
input-output examples and this is the
definition that was kind of lurking in
theory literature but we pulled out and
and made concrete and now underlies a
large fraction of block cipher usages so
we saw that electronic code book mode is
insecure and we also saw that cbc is
highly used and potentially is more
secure due to the fact that it's
randomized but it would be nice to know
whether they're actually our attacks of
the form that there are nice eb and
roughly speaking the answer we gave in
in our work on the subject was that it
is secure meaning that it meets the
notion of security we just outlined as
long as you assume that the block cipher
is itself good so this is this gives us
some confidence that this notion is
right and supports the fact that if you
using it right now across you know
hundreds of thousands of platforms out
there it's it's actually it actually
works now just as a recall underlying
these two strings here are the formal
def
we talked about this is the formal
security go for encryption which
captures very strong security
requirements and this is the assumption
we make on the block cipher which is
stronger than usual but is necessary to
get any kind of conclusions about the
usage of the primitive now that's kind
of an informal statement that doesn't
give you the concrete view and this is
how it would look in a concrete security
setting so here the theorem doesn't say
something about security or not it just
gives you a numerical relation between
the success probabilities of adversaries
it says that if you give me an attacker
on the encryption scheme and it has some
resource user should see some number of
encryptions of messages of some length
and as some running time i will build
for you an attacker against the block
cipher and their successes are related
in this way and you read that as saying
that as long as this quantity is small
meaning the block ciphers secure the
inequality tells you that this is small
as long as the resource users of your
attacker doesn't get to be too big and
the nice thing about this is that you
can get numbers out of it so for example
if you encrypt this many messages of
this length and you want security
against an attacker with this much
running time you can plug it into the
formula and under appropriate
assumptions on the block cipher and
let's say we're using AES so that we
have 128-bit block lengths the formula
will tell you how much success
probability your adversity will have
yeah that's right yeah okay so I guess
I'd say something about that there's a
term here that in some sense becomes the
bottle net to getting good security out
of this this term is not an artifact of
the analysis as long as you are
targeting this type of security notion
this reflects birthday attacks that can
actually happen now you might debate
whether those attacks are important in
practice but if we take the position
that encryption is something that needs
to be deployed in a way that's kind of
application oblivious it's it should
work for any application then they're
important and this term grows fast
enough that if you use des you'll get
very little security out of it in fact
even with a yes you probably get less
out of this than I really like but
anyway so in conclusion this sort of
exemplifies the whole path we followed
it talks about how we use confusion
diffusion primitives here the block
cipher and made assumptions about them
we were able to analyze symmetric
cryptography used in practice get
provable security results about it and
in concrete security settings that gave
us back numbers that we could interpret
okay my second example is about
integrity of data so here what's
happening is that the message is being
transmitted and Bob wants to make sure
that when he gets a message really
originates with Alice and not someone
else to do that Alice attaches a tag
called a Mac also computer under the
secret key that they share note that the
message is transmitted in the clear
we're not trying to achieve security
here we won't go into this formally but
roughly the security goal is that it
should be hard to produce a Mac of a
message without knowing the key so this
functions is a kind of fingerprint which
only the holders of the key can produce
and vouches for the fact that the
message is authentic now historically
max were built based on block ciphers
and in particular the DES base CBC Mac
was over the first and most widely used
ones but later on hash function started
appearing and this character should be a
membership symbol i guess my font some
two machines are not the same so yeah so
hash functions had the nice property
that they were faster than block ciphers
they were present at the time in
software and so people wanted to look at
them for a basil to use here now maybe a
little useful forward we're going to do
to think say a little what hash
functions look like hash functions
themselves are built on the principle
we've seen before of transforming
some atomic primitive to a high level
one the atomic primitive there is a
compression function and it's repeated a
number of times in some way to hash data
of arbitrary length there are standard
property of the hash function is what's
called collision resistance which means
it should be hard to find two different
inputs or the same output even though
mathematically of course they're these
kinds of collisions are bound due to the
fact that the hash function output is a
fixed length like 160 bits and inputs
are arbitrary length so when you start
thinking about using hash functions for
the purpose of maps message
authentication the basic bottleneck you
have is that these primitives don't take
keys and message authentication depends
crucially on use of a secret key so how
do we put a key into there well various
proposals like this were made but
eventually my colleagues at IBM Canadian
craft chick and I came up with this
proposal called H Mac and it's quite
simple all it does is prepended key to
the input and hash except that it then
takes the output and repeats the process
so it hashes twice and there are a
couple of things about this design that
made it attractive one is that we could
prove some sort of security properties
we could prove that it's a secure
message authentication code under
appropriate assumptions and the
Assumption here was what people was
assuming typically of the hash function
its collision resistant and secondly we
also needed an assumption on the
underlying compression function that it
satisfied a notion called being a
pseudo-random function which you don't
have to know exactly what it means in
depth at this at this moment so
additionally however H Mac was practical
in the sense that was efficient just two
applications of the hash function easy
to implement because it made only black
box use of the hash function and
possibly these are some explanations
barring luck I suppose of the fact that
each Mac is now widely used Microsoft
uses it and it's the only understand
what's called automatic
approved to implement Mac it recently
became a government standard it was used
in IPSec TLS SSL pretty much everywhere
so with this kind of deployment security
becomes crucial and the story of each
Mac interestingly continues into quite
recent times with the fact that hash
functions turned out to be a lot less
secure than we thought so you already
saw professor Wang on a previous slide
and she showed that md5 which was a hash
function you treat H Mac is used quite
broadly is not collision resistant and
neither is on sha-1 this may not be now
when people tried to extend those
attacks to H Mac they found that they
couldn't so the attacks don't actually
break H Mac the king and the structure
somehow prevents that but it had an
interesting theoretical consequence
which is that the result justifying
security effectively became vacuous not
because the theorem was wrong but
because one of the assumptions was false
you can view as what Professor Lang is
saying is simply that since the hash
function is not collision resistant this
theorem effectively says false implies
true which is which is always true so I
returned to this a little bit after
these attacks based on the fact that
people were kind of questioning even
though each mag didn't have wasn't
broken whether the lack of a proof
should mean that one should consider
removing it as a standard and what I did
was prove that each Mac continues to be
secure even if this assumption isn't
true so nearly the second assumption is
enough to guarantee security the good
thing about that is that the second
assumption is not refuted by any known
attacks and so this reestablished a
proof base guarantee and at least to
some extent was influential in
maintaining confidence in the standards
but I think it would be unrealistic to
end there I should note that even given
this proof and even given the fact that
H mac with md5 is not completely
destroyed at this point I definitely
don't encourage its use crypt analysis
of it
continues and gets better and better and
I personally don't believe that it's
going to stand up in the future so you
do want to make sure that you have hash
functions which are likely to have the
property you need for the proof to be
true and this seems to be much better
with later hash functions such as shark
256 yeah the proof bail is each my MD 5
mins is it the secure server and
function film so in that sense the
situation that was before comes back in
the sense that if you simply add some
attack showing that md5 its compression
function is not so random you wouldn't
necessarily break H Mac so again the
proof is not capturing everything that's
there but conceivably I would imagine
that H Mac md5 will eventually itself
just be attacked somehow in particular
yeah although I think that could be
proved before there's an attack yeah
since since 96 hatches of go around
slower and they got more secure and for
the day implies that this happened when
exporting happy would not send you to
jail in sporting director who would send
you to jail what's not to do it again in
this century you still use ashes as a
base for max that's a good point in
something nowadays for example even the
performance gap is this job so I es as
much faster than des was is not clear
there would be such a strong motivation
anymore so at this point use of H Mac is
largely entrenched and sir ok so i guess
i can quickly do my last example which
was a symmetric encryption so here we in
the public key setting and bob will
Alice wants to encrypt a message she can
do that given kind of public information
about Bob in the form of all I can think
of a like a public phone number which
Bob can decrypt with a secret key and
again our goal is privacy largely
speaking in practice we use RSA
encryption the public key here is a
number called a modulus and an
encryption exponent one madam
much of you don't know how these work
and there's a corresponding secret key
over here so when the tackle building
encryption schemes with RSA we need to
make use of the mathematical RSA
function what cryptographers like to
think of this as is what's called a
one-way trapdoor function this means
that if i give you the public key the
modulus an exponent and i give you an
input X it's easy to compute the value
of the function which is defined by
raided raising X to the power e and then
doing that modular modulo n similarly if
i give you the decryption exponent and
the modulus it's actually easy to go
backwards and go from f of X back to X
but as long as you don't have this
decryption key d here it's currently not
known how you can reverse this process
now I'd like to add that one important
technicality that our understanding or
at least the formal assumption about
this relates to when X was chosen at
random if I choose X at random and give
you f of X don't give you the decryption
key no one knows how to go backwards now
when our essay was introduced based on
the diffie-hellman type paradigm it was
generally thought that we've solved
public key encryption because that is
encryption just let the encryption be
this and well you can encrypt and
decrypt and the adversary can traverse
the encryption process without the
secret key the difficulty is that this
function although you cannot get em back
from F of em can reveal partial
information or some pieces of
information about the message and that's
not what we want for for good encryption
so that puts us back in the position
we've seen many times by now which is
that we want to create an encryption
scheme viewing the RSA function as an
low-level primitive and the encryption
scheme is a high level one and the
question is how do we actually do that
do the transform so one thing that will
be necessary is randomization because
without that we will not meet the kind
of strong security goals that I talked
about in the symmetric setting and that
extend here
now in theory this problem was solved
using something called hardcore bits and
they can tell you that they can provably
encrypt with RSA in this method but when
you look at this from a practical
perspective where you hit a performance
bottlenecks so every encryption here
each RSA operation only encrypts one
message bit if I were 128-bit message I
have a hundred over a hundred thousand
bits of ciphertext and plus I need a lot
of RSA operations so what practitioner
said is let's do something very simple
we we know that you can't let the
message be the object to which the RSA
function f is applied so let's throw in
a little bit of randomness and pad out
the message with that and then encrypt
well across the fence the comment about
this was not that we know how to break
it they didn't know how to break it but
to be careful about this because it's no
longer the case that you can prove
security of this method based on the
assumption we'd like to make about our
essay which that it's one way so if this
works we don't really understand why and
that's kind of a cautionary a way to
look at it well as long as none the less
deep for performance reasons this turned
out to be widely deployed as a standard
introduced by RSA security and from then
into pretty much every standard out
there and this is what gets used it
turned out that the pessimists were
right in this case so eventually attacks
emerged and ensure that there were
different ways to compromise p kc s one
of these is what's called a chosen
ciphertext attack where by an attacker
with some sort of limited actresses to a
decryption box can break the scheme and
this turned out to be relevant to the
use of pkc s in ssl which is why this
cert advisory went out but later even
stronger what a call so chosen plaintext
attacks in march where certain types of
messages could simply be recovered from
the from the ciphertext what we proposed
as an alternative was something called a
aep which follows the pkgs paradigm in
saying that we only want to apply f once
and we want to be able to put a large
number
message bits into any in a single
encryption so what it does is it takes
the message add some redundancy and then
takes a random number here this is a
randomization and processes are shown
based on a couple of public functions to
produce some output and then the RSA
function is applied to that okay so what
was good about this is that it had some
kind of provable sick support under the
assumptions and theoreticians like to
make which is that RSA is one way and
under the essa and another assumption
that i will discuss more and more depth
later which is that these functions are
what I call random Oracle's we could
prove security against plain chosen
plaintext attacks it turns out you can
also prove security against chosen
ciphertext attacks which is what you
need to prevent the kind of thing that
like and barker talked about now the
benefit of this is that it meets both
the practical and theoretical
constraints on the efficiency side it's
as efficient as the broken scheme that
the practitioners wanted but it had some
kind of security proof and again that
turned out to be attractive for usage so
oap is also in a whole bunch of
standards and and software across the
world and so forth now the story has a
kind of embarrassing component as well
in our original paper we had actually
claimed not only this security but
security against the stronger attacks
and we got that wrong luckily for us
some the fact itself wasn't false so
other reach researchers fill the gap
soon after it was pointed out but I
think it did it reflects something about
proofs and also the fact that in those
days we just had so much to do that we
were going really really fast and we
kind of missed some things so I'd like
to stalk a little bit about the
methodology behind that result and
particular this fact about random
Oracle's which have become another
rather widely used method so the random
Oracle paradigm was something that Phil
and I created exactly in order to bridge
this gap between theory and practice
where
you didn't seem to be able to produce
schemes of the kind of efficiency that
practitioners needed and yet have
security proves and what we noticed is
that the building blocks used in
practice had properties that were not
captured by theoretical definitions but
seemed very strong which is in
particular that things like hash
functions were built to resemble to have
random behavior and we wanted to try to
capture that so we created this model
based on some inspiration by Fiat and
shamir where you have access to a box
which implements a random function that
just means that when you call this think
of it as a as a piece of software
somewhere out there on the internet it
has simply returned a random number
except that it's nice enough to be
consistent if you try asking the same
question it gives you the same thing
back so this is in fact a complete noise
box it does nothing of any discernible
value just gives you random stuff
nonetheless this turns out to be just
about the most useful cryptographic
primitive you can imagine and what we
did is show how large number of schemes
can be proved secure in this model now
at first glance that's quite useless
because the random Oracle is effectively
a thought experiment so our next step
was to say that when you want a
practical scheme you replace this random
Oracle with the hash function and in
that way you were built we were able to
get highly efficient schemes with
security proofs in this model the caveat
from a theoretical perspective is that
the security proofs applied in the
random Oracle morally didn't apply to
the instantiated final scheme and this
aspect has led to the random Oracle
model being highly debated and
controversial in particular people have
shown that it's possible to find
counterexample schemes which are secure
in the random Oracle model but once you
use the hash function they fail and that
might sound like a problem except that
these counter examples all artificial
they kind of built to fail and real
schemes that does this doesn't seem to
happen the random Oracle model is
probably one of the most popular things
we've done it's used
enormously one just one such instances
it was used for the first ide scheme by
and large the practical schemes on based
on it have not failed but the
theoretical questions and raises are
quite interesting because nobody knows a
really sound theoretical way to bridge
the gap between the random Oracle model
in the instantiation and this kind of
reflects to some extent fill in my
philosophy which is that when we had a
choice between choosing between theory
and practice we chose practice in the
sense that we were willing to sacrifice
the proofs to the largest extent to the
minimal extent possible to bridge the
efficiency gaps and thereby we created
this kind of hybrid methods I don't know
much to say about the where things are
going but my particular interests are in
pushing cryptography to the point where
it's even more aware of what goes on in
practice in software systems than now
and another direction i'm interested in
is in making theory more understandable
and proves more verifiable by by tools
to do these things I'm sorry I haven't
had time to talk about my more recent
work and but I worked a lot of many of
these topics and I'm happy to get into
that any time in offline so so I'll stop
there thank you
yeah you said several times get some
randomness now where you get random
isn't is the real system yeah that's
something that guys can't guess that's
right so that's certainly one of these
sort of problems where yeah it's not
clear how to do it so of course they're
all these standard heuristics you take
system parameters and you hash them and
you do things but yeah all these things
presume high quality randomness so
that's another one of these gaps that no
yeah so the random Oracle is a thought
experiment so it's not pseudo-random
it's perfectly random so when you use a
pseudo-random generator you are
approximating it to a certain extent but
that approximation is something I don't
know how to capture in any formal way so
heuristic alee it might work but there
are somehow no guarantees about it okay
yeah sorry can you define sort of the
difference between actually security
analysis and then the cryptography where
the security was looking in viruses and
other ways to get things and you said
you were going to concentrate on the
crypt analysis although this later on
you did mention some attacks that use
like the looking for electricity changes
and so how much in practice can you
really separate those two yeah that's a
good point so in practice that they're
harder to separate then in theory and
but there's a lot of work at both ends i
think in pushing theoretical models
deeper into systems to capture this and
on the other side to make cryptography
aware of what's going on in systems for
example one thing I've worked on is
protecting against break-ins by forward
security where the key evolves with time
so this is ting gets broken into at a
certain point in time you only lose the
current key but this is a huge area of
of problems and issues for for security
in general we're largely things are open
yeah Charles you were saying
oh yeah it was it was a merger so this
thing huh okay I guess that's it then